he's the old star pitcher for the LA
Dodgers Clayton Kershaw back on the
program good morning Clayton how are you
I'm good morning
ah you care who wins the NBA Finals no
okay
I watch I do it I think I kind of think
the Warriors are gonna it's not going to
be as closer but I thinks it is but yeah
I'll enjoy the games for her do you like
you watch the Lakers your Laker fan or
do you have to be a Laker fan yeah I
have to be like a fan mom you know I
grew up in Dallas so I fallen as a lot
Dirk is found my guy I love their heat
awesome did you go to the finals when
Dirk won his championship against LeBron
yes my buddy my buddy found ticket
scalping tickets and so we were like at
the top like nosebleed we didn't go to
the crunching game but we went to a lot
of games it was awesome
wait wait wait didn't you have any juice
to get good tickets back then no I know
I'm not yet
I didn't have that you said when did you
get juice in LA that's a good question
you know I think I'm not great at that
stuff I don't know how that all that
stuff works how people have you know I
got this guy I know somebody that knows
somebody just like I don't I don't know
all that stuff but every once in a while
like his humbleness and good cleated
yeah but you need a guy who will make
the call to say hey I'm calling for
Clayton Kershaw he'd like to sit
courtside at the lakers and he would
like to go to this sushi restaurant yeah
I know
apparently you need a guy for that I
don't I just do it myself calling your
reservation sometimes some desperate
I'll ask my sister-in-law cuz she kind
of works for our foundation so I'll call
her you okay she's name drops I'm too
embarrassed name drop so sometimes it
happens but it ball it's before the time
what what did you make of the Bryce
Harper situation with the Giants and
under stricken from a pitchers
perspective perspective it sure looks
like he's holding on to a grudge from
you know a few years back and I mean I
was definitely on purpose and I can get
banished and my Bryce was a little upset
okay have you held a grudge
do you hold a grudge with anybody right
now that I should Nova um I mean those
computers I don't like obviously but but
what do they do like what did they do to
make you be mad at them but it for me
it's more about uh you know just
on-field antics more than if you get
hits off me or not you know guys that
get tipped off me and go about it the
right way and you know if they hit
homers they don't just stand there and
stare at it for a really long time you
know I'm ok with that but uh you know
the antics are probably what gets me to
have some grudges what happens what's
that moment like when somebody leaves
the batter's box going to the mound have
you had that feeling recently you know I
better don't know if I'm allowed to
admit that I've hit a few guys on
purpose in my day but I think you have
yeah so you know I I haven't had anybody
you know start that walk out so I don't
I don't know yet to be honest which do
you drop you are you ready for do you
have a game plan here have you discussed
this with teammates your wife if this
happens this is what I do
all my life would be so mad if they
happened she would not appreciate that
at all she doesn't like it when I trip
it umpires or if I get any type of piss
on the field but she also knows it's
part of it but yeah I mean I have a game
plan I mean I in my head I know exactly
what I'm to do it's going to be like a
Kyle Armour situation let's go up there
and a faculty guy but I'm also not as
big and strong as Kyle Farnsworth quote
oh how long I don't know exactly how
it's going to work out just have to pick
the right hitter I guess you know you're
going to hit somebody on purpose does
the catcher need to know or anybody else
need to know you're going to hit
somebody on purpose hypothetically here
please yeah I mean the catcher is so the
catcher can kind of get in the way if
you wanted to I think that's important
you know I think that's you know usually
most of the time it's so premeditated
that everybody kind of knows what's
going on you know well yeah it's a
tricky thing because I'm trying to
understand when somebody needs to be hit
and at least in the national league
you're going to the plate whereas these
guys in your article ache when you're
not going to the plate I have a big
problem with that
you yes yes if you're throwing a
baseball at somebody they can't throw
their bat at you so right all they can
do is go to the mound they go to the
mound Bryce Harper gets three games and
Hunter Strickland gets six to me and I
would have sat down Strickland for 15
games he reads anymore and he did it on
purpose he's a reliever Clayton yeah so
I in that situation there was no there
it didn't I don't know the back story
but it doesn't look like other than the
homers advice' it doesn't look like
there's a reason for him to hit it but
in certain situations you know you have
to protect your teammates and so I feel
like in the American League yes the
pitcher is not hitting but you have to
know that if you hit somebody without
you know premeditation or anything like
that then your best hitter more than
likely is going to get hit so you know
you're going to have to answer to that
and so I feel like that that's almost
worse than getting hit yourself is to
put your best hitter you know on like
that
have you ever apologized to a hitter oh
yeah I mean I think I've liked like
Gundam bad to the chest before yeah I
think yeah you don't you know I said you
know one of the ones I remember is a hit
braggart and hit his finger and I broke
his finger and he was out for you know a
month or something and that left her you
know I obviously feel terrible you don't
want to do that so yeah there are
certain situations where I think an
apology is necessary Dodger pitcher
Clayton Kershaw joining us did you ever
consider being a closer uh no I think
I've kind of always been a starter so
you know I think closing fun though that
one time I did it but could you do that
though it's a whole different mentality
that you have getting geared up when you
go to the ballpark knowing that there's
a chance you're going to pitch as
opposed to there's no chance that I'm
pitching yeah you know I love doing
starting pitcher I can't imagine you
know not having that like set routine
every five days and just going through
that just kind of showing to the
ballpark and it would be fun because you
wouldn't he'd be in the action more so I
would enjoy that but kind of knowing
that every fifth day is your day and he
kind of control the game that day and
whether you could scared you when
jeepers graduated or that you look at
all these guys that everybody seems to
be clocking in at 95 miles an hour and
you don't have to
and I I still maintain I would like to I
mean what's it what's the hardest she
ever through uh you know I don't know I
think I mean I back back in my younger
days after I think I got up there pretty
good but they age kind of and throws and
I lose a little bit over time but don't
you think you're better because you
don't you don't rely on throw 90 font
you you pitch you don't throw and that's
what a lot of these guys now just throw
hello relievers you know you can do that
you know you get away with that you
throw a 95 with you know one incredible
off-speed pitch you're going to be a
pretty successful out of the bullpen if
you don't have to face guys multiple
times over and over again but yeah as a
starter you know I think he's Li the
best ones are the one with the deuteron
archive would also know how to pitch you
know I think those are the you know I
don't think there's a ton of guys you
know off the top of my head but you know
Dallas Keuchel the first one that comes
to mind that doesn't light up the radar
gun but watching him pitch is pretty
impressive the way he can go about a
lineup Dodgers in first place hounds
maroon good for playing good man we have
a great paint you know Jake has been out
for ten days or so and jocks been out
for a week or so I think we're like nine
and two in our last 11 games or
something so just a testament to the
depth we had we've had a lot of guys
step up play really well so it's a fun
time right now how many kids do we have
now I had a good yeah I got a
two-year-old in the six month old oh man
yeah awesome what sport are they gonna
play you know I was talking I don't know
you know I my wife is a she loved
dancing she was a dancer you're not so I
think I think our daughter has no choice
there she's going to be a dancer and
then Charlie you know I hope he I hope
he plays first base honestly because I
know he's not gonna be fast if he has
any games like yes I have like
Thursday's and
um but you know football basketball you
know football tough you know I don't
know what to do about football I'm
working a play not a play I don't know
what to do there but um I'm really
looking forward to all that stuff I was
wrong but you talked to Stanford about
this that he plays the sport you're
friends with him and do you want your
kids to play football uh well he's got
twin girls right now so I don't know if
you have to worry about that yes but um
you know Matthew yeah I know I haven't
talked to him about it you know I think
quarterback I feel like I don't know I
mean you still get hit in the head it's
it's hard you know I think it's my son
want to play I think it'd be really hard
to stop him you know I don't want to
take that away from him but yeah just
because all the stuff that's coming out
and hopefully in 10 years when he's
ready to play there will be some new
helmet that I have to worry about
anymore well congrats on the season
always great to catch up with you thanks
for making time for us Clayton
all right very appreciate it thanks
Clayton Kershaw my LA Dodgers the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience